cloud bigtable is a nosql database that
has the scale speed and reliability
necessary to handle big data workloads
in previous episodes we learned about
some of bigtable's key features as well
as its data model
we also took a look at how bigtable is
being used in a diverse group of
industries like retail transportation
and fraud detection in this episode
we're going to learn more about how
bigtable can be used for a key use case
personalization
[Music]
across industries data is helping
businesses elevate the customer
experience to new heights
one particular area where data is
helping is personalization
delivering a tailored experience to each
customer based on their own unique needs
and preferences
personalization is all around us
if you're an online shopper you might
notice the product recommendations that
pop up based on your purchase history
if you use a video streaming service
you'll probably get recommendations for
new movies and tv shows based on what
you've watched in the past
and if you like music your digital music
service probably uses personalization to
help you discover new songs and
playlists data is at the heart of
personalization but this presents unique
challenges to businesses trying to
harness it
luckily bigtable is great for supporting
personalization at scale because of its
unique combination of scale speed and
reliability
personalization requires businesses to
store and access large volumes of data
bigtable is a highly scalable database
allowing you to store up to petabytes of
data
in fact bigtable supports trillions of
rows with millions of columns and each
row and bigtable supports up to 256
megabytes of data so you can easily
store all personalization data for an
individual customer in a single row
bigtable databases can be scaled
linearly at zero downtime by adding or
removing nodes each of which provides up
to 10 000 additional queries per second
and is attached to additional storage
capacity
personalization also requires a database
that can quickly write large volumes of
data concurrently for many users since
customer behavior needs to be
continually captured to inform future
recommendations
bigtable meets this challenge with the
ability to handle millions of read and
write requests per second
and it's able to do so at low latency on
the order of single digit milliseconds
this is critical for personalization
since you wouldn't want users to have to
wait around for personalized
recommendations
bigtable's flexible nosql data model
also works well for personalization
traditional relational databases assume
a fixed schema that will change
infrequently over time
but nosql databases relax the rigidity
of the schema and allow for data
structures to evolve much more easily
over time
another important aspect of the bigtable
data model is that its tables are sparse
meaning that if a column is not filled
in for a given row you don't pay for
that empty cell
in an e-commerce example you might have
a row for each customer and a column for
each product that they may have engaged
with
with bigtable's nosql data model it's
easy to add new columns to the table as
new products are introduced and if a
customer hasn't engaged with a given
product that cell will be empty and you
don't end up paying for its space
because bigtable tables are sparse
of course storing customer information
is only one step to performing
personalization at scale
the next step is finding ways to make
that data useful using machine learning
and big data analysis tools bigtable has
you covered with easy integration with
google tools like bigquery tensorflow
dataproc and data flow as well as apache
tools like hbase hadoop beam and spark
we've covered just a few of the key
reasons why bigtable is great for
personalization but other reasons
include low total cost of ownership or
tco for high throughput workloads
consistent performance around the world
because of data replication across
google data centers internationally
and business critical reliability with
up to 99.999
availability sla
let's take a look at an example of how
big table tables could be used for an
e-commerce website looking to recommend
products to users based on their viewing
and purchase history
first we might have a user history table
this table stores information about user
sessions including which products they
viewed add to their cart and purchased
next we could have a user
personalization table
this table stores recommended products
for each user which will be generated
dynamically over time using machine
learning
it can also store user's own stated
preferences from a wish list of saved
items
and finally we might have a product
recommendation table this will provide
product recommendations based on an
original product
for example if a customer bought a blue
t-shirt we might recommend them other
types of blue t-shirts
so there you have it an overview of how
bigtable's speed scalability and
reliability makes it great for
personalization use cases
if you're curious to learn more follow
the links below for more information
thanks for joining us today and stay
tuned for more episodes about bigtable